Hallo, können wir anfangen?
Ja, bitte schön.
Ulud ist mein Name, ich bin die zuständige Ärztin für Sie und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen
das Anamnespäche-Preführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne Frau Doktor.
Danke.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, ich möchte einige Personie-Hedatler fragen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Michael Balak.
Balak, K am Ende.
Zika.
Herr Balak, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
45 Jahre alt.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,85 m und wege 80 kg.
80 kg.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Balak?
Ich bin Krankenpfleger.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin Single.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Herr Balak, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, was führt Sie so?
Ja, Frau Doktor, es ist ein folgendes Problem.
Ich fühle mich seit ungefähr einer Woche nicht mehr so gut.
Ich fühle mich körperlich schwach.
Und ich habe noch ein paar andere Beschwerden seit einer Woche wechselhaft.
Ich habe noch ein paar Schwerden,
dass ich immer ein bisschen Temperatur habe.
Haben Sie das gemessen?
Ja, es war so 37, 37, 3.
Und an der Appetit ist seit einer Woche nicht gut.
Ich habe Übelkeit, also kann ich nicht gut essen.
Ich habe auch so Gelenkbeschwerden wie bei so einem krippalen Infekt.
Ich hatte zwischendurch auch mal 2 Tage,
wo mein Stuhl auch dünn war.
Ich will es nicht durchfallen,
aber ich habe den letzten Stuhl wieder normal.
Ich habe hier oben ein Druckgefühl in der Magengegend.
Was das Hauptproblem ist,
ist, dass ich seit gestern aufgefahren habe,
dass meine Augen gelb geworden sind.
Haben Sie beschwerden, plötzlich begonnen?
Ich habe sie seit einer Woche ungefähr, wie ich schon sagte.
Aber das mit der Gelb-Färbung ist mir gestern auch gefallen.
Gestern Abend?
Haben Sie ganze Körper schwächeln oder nur Arme, Beine?
Ich fühle mich so, ich fühle mich so wie kripp an.
Ich fühle mich kripp.
Schönen Sie sich müde?
Ja.
Haben Sie keine Übelkeit oder?
Doch, ich habe Übelkeit auch nicht.
Entschuldigung.
Sie haben Übelkeit, haben Sie schon erbrochen?
Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Erbrochen habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig auch?
Ich bewege mich nicht viel, insofern kann ich nicht sagen es.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Gelenkmärzen haben.
Haben Sie auch Schwälung am Gelenk bemalt?
Nein.
Sind Ihre Gelenke heißer geworden?
Nein, es ist von außen nichts zu erkennen.
Das ist so wie bei der Krippe.
Wissen Sie, wenn Sie die Gelenk überlebt, tut.
Ja.
Haben Sie Farbeveränderungen der Haut bemalt?
Ja, wie ich schon sagte, dass die Augen gelb geworden sind.
Nein, ich meine ganze Körper.
Ja, vielleicht, wenn ich jetzt weiß, dass meine Augen gelb sind,
dann meine ich, dass die Haut vielleicht auch ein bisschen gelb ist.
Aber hauptsächlich sind die Augen aufgewöhnt.
Keine andere Lesionen, besonders am Beinen?
Nein.
Waren Sie letzter Woche im Wald oder im Ausland?
Also, ich war vor ungefähr sechs Wochen im Ausland, in Thailand.
Waren Sie schon dort im Wald?
Im Wald?
Nein, ich war am Strand.
Haben Sie dort etwas ungewöhnliches gegessen oder getrunken?
Also, das, was man im Urlaub ist, man, das ist ein anderes Essen.
Ich konnte das nicht verstanden.
Das, was man im Urlaub ist, in einem fremden Land.
Ich habe gegessen, was die dort auch kochen und essen.
Ich kann nicht, Ola.
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Im Urlaub habe ich so gegessen, wie die Leute auch dort im Land essen.
Also, Thai Essen.
Könnten Sie, ah okay, traditionelle Essen haben Sie gegessen,
aber Sie wissen nicht, was es enthalten wird.
Also, ich habe viele Sachen gegessen.
Ja, ja, verstehe ich.
Im Urlaub ging es mir gut.
Haben Sie Schmerzen auch?
Ja, wir haben so ein Druck, Druck auf viele Magen, da kommt auch die Übelkeit her.
Diese Druckgefühl, nur im Magenbereich?
Nein, in der Magengänge hier so oben.
Ich habe auch noch etwas mit gehabt, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Haben Sie Sortbränen damit?
Sortbränen habe ich nicht, nein.
Können Sie diese Druckgefühl betreffen, wenn Sie sich anders legen?
Ist immer gleich.
Könnten Sie beschreiben, wie müde fühlen Sie sich?
Sie können alltägliche Aufgabe erledigen?
Das geht schon noch, ja.
Aber ich könnte jetzt nicht arbeiten.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Herzschase?
Nicht gemerkt, nein.
Können Sie gut Luft kriegen, fühlen Sie...
Ich habe keine Atembeschwerte.
Haben Sie Konzentrationsverlust?
Können Sie einfach alles konzentrieren?
Ja, seit einer Woche geht es mir insgesamt nicht gut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Konzentrationsschwierigkeiten sind,
aber ich kann es nicht.
Ich kann es nicht.
Ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren, wenn Sie das meinen.
Sess nicht, oder?
Sess nicht?
Sess ist sehr gut, ein Problem mit Aytan.
Ich hoffe, dass es nicht wieder geht.
Wir haben ja Internet,
ich sitze bei mir,
aber es geht noch nicht gut.
Seit einer Woche geht es mir nicht gut.
Deswegen habe ich auch seit einer Woche
Konzentrationsschwierigkeiten, kann ich sagen.
Könnten Sie das genau beschreiben?
Können Sie sich selbst ausdrücken?
Können Sie etwas lesen, verstehen?
Das kann ich schon.
Ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren,
dass ich etwas arbeiten könnte.
Das geht mir nicht so schlecht.
Haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches beim Wasser?
Der Urin ist mir aufgefallen, dass er dunkel ist.
Er ist mir heute aufgefallen.
Ich habe auch darauf geachtet.
Sie haben gesagt,
dass er seit einer Woche nicht konzentriert.
Sie haben gesagt, dass er seit einer Woche nicht gut ist.
Sie haben in letzter Zeit ungewollt.
Aber genau so.
Höchstens in der letzten Woche,
aber nicht viel, 1-2 kg maximal.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass eine kurze Zusammenfassung ist.
Sie haben seit einer Woche eine Müdigkeit.
Sie haben ein bisschen Müdigkeit.
Aber Sie haben nicht Albrecht.
Sie haben Gelenkschmerzen.
Seit gestern sind Ihre Augen Geld geworden.
Sie haben ein Druckgefühl im Margenbereich.
Sie haben keine Schmerzen.
Sie haben ein bisschen Müdigkeit.
Sie haben eine Müdigkeit.
Ansonsten haben Sie keine starken Schmerzen.
Sie haben keine andere Lesion.
Sie haben keine Herzdrahse, keine Atemloch.
Ja, ich sehe das.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Nein, das sind die wichtigsten Beschwerden.
Sie haben alles aufgeschrieben.
Sie haben Ihre Vorabschranken gelesen.
Sie haben keine Zuckerkrankheit.
Kein Zucker, kein Blutdruck.
Ich habe nur diese Gastriestbeschwerden.
Manchmal nehme ich auch die Pantopazol-Tabletten ein.
Nehmen Sie das regelmäßig ein?
Ansonsten nicht regelmäßig.
Ich habe letztes Jahr einen Fahrradunfall gehabt.
Dann muss ich ins Krankenhaus.
Ich habe es in der Stadt.
Ich hatte eine Milz-Ruptur.
Da muss man notoperiert werden.
Da ist die Milz entfernt worden.
Da war ich auch im Schock-Kaum.
Was ich auch noch erwähnen kann.
Ich habe immer wieder auch ein Nadelstich-Verletzungen.
Wenn ich im Arbeiten unversicht bin,
habe ich mich auch mit den Finger gestorben.
Das war das letzte Mal vor 4 Jahren.
Ich habe wieder eine Nadelstich-Verletzung gehabt.
Könntest du das genau beschreiben?
Ich habe einen Patienten an der Subkotane-Injektion gegeben.
Dann habe ich die Hülle drauf.
Ich habe die Finger gestorben.
War es ansteckend?
Wir haben nicht geguckt.
Es war ein Patient, der mit den Finger gestorben ist.
Ich habe ihn vor 4 Monaten geschaut.
Wir haben nicht geguckt.
Es war ein Patient, der nur 2 Tage im Krankenhaus war.
Ich weiss nicht, ob er etwas Ansteckendes hat.
Das war letztes Jahr, oder?
Nein, das war vor 4 Monaten.
Haben Sie die Ergebnisse von dieser Patient gefolgt?
Ich habe es nicht verfolgt.
Es ist mir aber auch schon oft passiert.
Ich arbeite schon seit 20 Jahren in der Krankenpflege.
Ich habe schon mindestens 20 oder 30 Nadelstich-Verletzungen gehabt.
Ich habe das nicht immer verfolgt.
Sie haben verfolgt.
Als Medikamente nehmen Sie noch einen Grundprosok.
2 Bedarfs.
Aber seit einiger Woche regelmäßig.
Noch nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein.
Keine anderen Medikamente?
Wir sind letztes Jahr wegen Unfall operiert.
Und gibt es noch eine andere Operation?
Nein.
Keine andere Operation.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin geimpft.
Sie sind auch gegen Hepatitis geimpft?
Wenn dann schon lange her.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Ich glaube, Hepatitis B hatte ich eine Impfung gehabt.
Ich habe sie auch etwas allergisch.
Nein.
Haben Sie Unfall-Träglichkeiten?
Keine.
In Ihrer Familie gibt es chronische Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Meine Mutter hat Diabetes, Bluthochdruck.
Mein Vater hat mal Gift gehabt.
Er hat Schilddrösenprobleme.
Er hat Schilddrösen überfühlt.
Und Ihre Mutter hat Diabetes und Bluthochdruck.
Herr Schballack,
lassen Sie uns über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten sprechen.
Brauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Seit wann und wie viel?
Schon so 20 Jahre,
bestimmt schon halbe Speckchen pro Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu, nicht jeden Tag,
aber drei, vier Mal die Woche,
vielleicht ein bis zwei Fleisch Bier.
Haben Sie schon mal Rogen probiert?
Ja, aber schon lange her.
Wann und wie hoch?
Einmal?
Ja, ein paar Mal.
Ich habe das vergessen zu fragen.
Schwitzen Sie in der Nacht?
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Wie sieht Ihre Stuhlgang aus?
War bisher normal.
Sie haben gesagt, dünner,
aber ich möchte wirklich die Farbe wissen.
Die Farbe war als normal.
Herr Schballack, ich denke, ich habe die wichtige Frage gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, das waren alles, was ich sagen wollte.
Als der Massname
würde ich gerne Sie Kokali unter suchen
und bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und ein paar Sachen,
die Sie dann auch in der Nacht haben.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt,
ich möchte Blut abnehmen.
Und ein paar Bilder, wenn das Verfahren durchführen.
Wenn die Ergebnisse vorlegen,
können wir an die weitere Schritte diskutieren.
Ich muss da bleiben, Krankenhaus, was denken Sie?
Leider kann ich ganz genau nicht sagen.
Wenn die Ergebnisse vorlegen,
können wir darüber sprechen.
Okay, gut.
Okay, gibt es noch Fragen
von den anderen Teilnehmern?
Oder Kommentare?
Haben wir alles gefragt?
Haben Sie Zittern?
Zittern?
Nein, Kopfschmerzen oder ein bisschen, aber nicht viel.
Und ob er immun ging,
aber das weiß er nicht.
Er hat nicht geimpft worden,
als er mit dem Arbeiten angefangen hatte vor 20 Jahren.
Er ist gemaltet, diese Arbeitsung.
Nein, das ist nicht gemeldet.
Konnten Sie nachher
Ihre Hepatite-Antikörper bestimmen?
Hab ich nicht gemacht, nein.
Okay.
Noch andere Fragen?
Bei Patienten aus dem medizinischen Bereich,
wenn es Ärzte sind oder Pfleger,
dann sind sie vom Fach und kennen sich gut aus.
Dann können wir ein paar Sachen
im Detail besprechen,
oder auch einige Fachbegriffe
ohne Probleme anwenden.
Gib mir die Gymnasal-Federalitis.
Oder wo arbeiten Sie?
Ob es bei den Überschreiten der Arbeit ist.
Das ist ein Teil der Arbeit.
Es gibt viele, die ein bisschen
festgekürzt werden,
aber es geht nicht um die Giulia,
sondern um die Ärzte.
Es geht nicht um die Ärzte,
Danke.
Aber du weißt, dass es bei den Almenen eine Krankfläge ist.
Es ist wichtig.
Hast du einen?
Nein, wir wissen nicht.
Also bei den jungen Krankflägen.
Das ist nicht ein Teil der Krankfläge, aber es ist eine Problem.
Wir wissen nicht, aber bei den Krankflägen,
dass es eine oder andere Situation ist.
Das ist eine wichtige Frage.
Ich will nicht nachreden,
aber die Frage der stadtlichen Ausrichtung
über ihre sexuellen Ausrichtung,
die homosexuellen oder heterosexuellen.
Das ist eine große Frage.
Ich möchte die Frage stellen,
ob wir uns mit den Krankflägen
hätte ich gesagt, darüber möchte ich nicht sprechen, hätte ich gesagt jetzt, ja?
Kann ja auch sein, ich möchte darüber nicht sprechen, ja?
Können wir nur sagen, sind Sie mit Ihren Sexuellen Lebens zufrieden,
oder sind Sie sexuell aktiv?
Kann man fragen, zum Beispiel, ja.
Sollte man gerade bei so infektiösen Krankheiten immer machen, ja?
Oder haben Sie wechselnde Geschlechtspartner, oder solche Fragen, ja?
Häufig wechselnde Geschlechtspartner, zum Beispiel, ja?
Sollte man fragen, ja?
Oder haben Sie vergeschlechtes Geschlechtsverkehr?
Können wir das fragen?
Dann du ja, Mademois.
Oder haben Sie vergeschlechtsverkehr in Thailand zum Beispiel?
Verdächtigen?
Ja.
Oder gefährliches, wie können wir das ausdrücken?
Haben Sie Risiko-Kontakte gehabt oder risikoreiche Geschlechtsverkehr?
Wie sie stehen für das Gewissen?
Griechische, das ist Risiko-Kontakte.
Sagen Sie, wie Sie das ausdrücken?
Das sind Sie da, die collisions- leiden Sie?
Nein, das können sie nicht.
Wie Sie die Schworte
Was ist das für Sie?
Weil es normal ist.
Ja, das ist das.
Nein, es gibt keine Diskriminierung.
Es ist normal, wenn es aufgrund der Normale geht.
Der ist ein heterosexueller.
Er ist ein heterosexueller.
Das kann sein.
Aber ich glaube, das ist eine direkte Frage.
Das ist ein Infektiv.
Das ist über die Einführung.
Ja, das ist über die Einführung.
Was ist wiedergelesen?
Wann ist die Einführung?
Das ist über die Einführung.
Ich şey.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patient aufgenommen,
der mich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Das ist eine andere Einführung wie dein Wolf.
Michael Ballak ist ein 45-jähriger Patient, der 80 kg schwer und 185 cm groß ist.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen einer Woche bestehende Abgeschlägenheit fertig.
Mit Zugfäbrile Temperatur, neuseher ohne Womitus vorgestellt hat.
Der Patient klagt über Artralgie, Iktarus und Schwindelvertigo.
Er zeigte mit, dass er eine Stuhl mit normalen Farben hat.
Seit gestern hat er im Auge Iktarus bemerkt.
Im Fachbegriff?
Iktarus.
Er hat es bemerkt.
Seit einer Woche habe ich Artralgie und Appetit in Appetence auf.
Die Frage nach Hörlös, Dodder und Schwellung am Gelenk wurde verneint.
Er hat auch Druckgefühl im Epigastrium.
Ohne Plexus, ohne Sophräne.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er Gastritis.
Er nimmt Pantoprosal, aber bei Bedarf.
Seit einer Woche nehme er das regelmäßig.
Es sei wegen einem Unfall operiert.
Ziplenectomy sei durchgeführt worden.
Er gibt an, dass er vor vier Monaten einen Nadelstrichunfall hatte.
Er hat die Paramente von den Patienten nicht gefolgt.
Er sei gegen Corona vollständig, aber er konnte sich nicht erinnern,
ob er Hepatitisbeinfug gehabt hat oder nicht.
Er hat keine Erlärgen oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Er hat leider seine Mutter an der Betis und Bluthochdruck.
Er hat leider seinen Vater an die Hypertrose.
Er sei rauch und insgesamt habe er 10 Packungen geraucht.
Er trinkt Alkohol ab und zu, nur 3-4 Mal pro Woche.
Ein oder zwei Flasche.
Vor acht Monaten sei er in Thailand gewesen, aber damals hatte er keine Beschwerden gehabt.
Er sei Krankenpfleger von Bedarf, habe keine Kinder und lebe allein und sei Single.
Ich habe die Informationen weitergeleitet.
Laut einem Nistischenangaben und Risikofaktoren habe ich dann Verdacht auf Hepatitis.
Als die finanzielle Diagnose sollte ein Hemmellosis ausgeschlossen werden.
Und so sehe ich hier eine HIV Infektion auch ausgeschlossen werden.
Als Maßnahme würde ich diese Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Und als Laborparameter sollten Blutbild, Polyribin, Albumin, Leberparameter, Nierenparameter bestimmt halten.
Ich habe das auch vergessen.
Er habe auch Konzentration, Mangel und leichte Kopfschmerzen.
Bei den Laborwerten schauen Sie auch nach, was?
Wenn Sie schon Blut abnehmen und dann schauen Sie, Sie haben gesagt Leberwerte, Nierenwerke.
Und Antikörper gegen Hepatitis.
EGM und EGG.
Was für eine Hepatitis vermuten Sie bei den Patienten?
Sie haben eine risikoreiche Unfallnadelstree.
Nach meiner Wissens kann diese Inkubationperiode ein bisschen länger sein.
Es ist besonders mit Hepatitis, sie glaube ich.
Aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Er hat es im Geruf.
Er hat auch eine allgemeine Körperangehörige reduziert.
Allgemeinzustand, Müdigkeit, generalisierte Schmerzen.
Ich denke, diese können auch als Hinweis sein.
Auf was?
Diese können auch ein Hinweis sein.
Worauf?
Ja, Hepatitis.
Aber da gibt es verschiedene Formen von Hepatitis.
Wir gehen jetzt auf eine infektiösen Hepatitis aus.
Virale Hepatitis, das ist unser Verdacht.
Es kann Hepatitis B oder C sein.
Warum?
Welche Annamnistikangaben könnten auf B oder C deuten?
Wie wird denn die Leuchttür da tragen?
Sie manchmal mit Nadelstree Unfall nach meiner Wissen.
Wie mit Kontakt im Thailand kann er eine risikoreiche Kontakt haben.
Das kann ein Hinweis für Hepatitis B sein.
Sie haben gesagt, der Patient hatte eine Spenectomie gehabt.
Haben Sie ihn gefragt, ob er bei der Operation Blutprodukte bekommen hat?
Ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Ist das wahrscheinlich nicht bei der Spenectomie?
Ja, sehr wahrscheinlich.
Es ist wahrscheinlich nicht so,
dass es nicht so gut ist.
Es ist wahrscheinlich nicht so gut,
Wenn ein Patient diese Operation braucht,
dann bedeutet,
dass der Patient viel Blut verloren hat.
Es ist auch ein Hinweis auf eine
Spendenz, die es nicht so gut gibt.
Das kann es später sein.
Was kann es noch sein?
Kann es auch bei den Patienten Hepatitis A sein?
Ich denke nicht.
Sie war sehr in der Inkuberation.
Es ist kürzer.
Manche Menschen erleben diese Krankheit schon in der Kinder.
Das ist unwahrscheinlich.
Ich kann das nicht mehr Comics machen.
Aber leider kann ich mir nichts genau an Localkepssen erinnern.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das stimmt.
Die kann auch bis zu 2 Monaten dauern.
Ich habe sogar Fälle, wo es noch länger ist.
Es kann auch an calls A sein.
Die grandiärenفي Hungary
mit der Hygiene nicht so unproblematisch. Deswegen kann auch Herpatitis A sein, durchaus, kann sein.
Würde ich nicht ausschließen. Was ist bei Herpatitis A das Problem, wenn Sie den Patienten ins Krankenhaus aufnehmen?
Ja, Isolation ist wichtig. Diese Patientin sollte isoliert werden.
Richtig, genau. Wüssten Sie, Herpatitis B Patienten auch isolieren?
Nichts ganz genau isolieren, aber alle Mitarbeiter sollten darüber informiert werden.
Aber Sie müssen nicht isolieren. Herpatitis B und C Patienten werden nicht isoliert, aber Herpatitis A muss isoliert werden.
Das ist wichtig. Deswegen, solange Sie nicht wissen, was sie hat, würde ich isolieren.
Bis Sie den Ergebnis von den Antikörper-Tests haben. Das kann manchmal zwei Tage dauern, wenn Sie es schicken müssen.
Ja, okay. Sehr gut. Okay, dann gucken wir noch, was wir im Chat gesehen haben.
Also, ich habe mit Laborel gesagt, Billio Bin, genau, Lieberwerte, ASTA, Gerinnung, Parameter.
Ja, das haben Sie gefragt und gesagt schon. Okay.
Was ist das, was Schlimmes, Herpatitis? Oder ist das Sache, die harmlos ist?
Es gibt eine Größe oder Spektrum, eine lange Spektrum, oder wie kann man das sagen?
Es ist unterschiedlich, aber manchmal, Herpatitis A ist nicht so gefährlich
und manche Menschen kann sogar das mit leichter Symptome oder asymptomatisch diese Krankheit erleben.
Aber Billio und sie kann chronisch bleiben,
deshalb gibt es andere Nebenwirkungen oder Langzeitkomplikationen damit.
Es gibt höchstes Risiko für Hepatosellilagparsinomaup und Serozilabarsirosis.
Richtig, ja. Sehr gut. Okay.
Und ganz selten gibt es mal jetzt nicht diesen chronisches Problem, sondern das akute Problem.
Was ist das akute Problem bei Herpatitis?
Allgemein A, B und C. Kann es Leber insuffisien sein?
Wie nennt man das dann? Wenn es akut schlechter wird?
Fullminan Herpatitis.
Genau, richtig. Die ist bei A gering, bei B und C bis häufiger, ja.
Und bei E ist sie am häufigsten.
Und wenn B und D oder S Gap ein auch Superinfektion für Herpatitis,
und ich glaube, das war die Gefährlichste, oder?
Also die Co-infektion B und D ist häufig.
Ja.
Genau.
Es gibt bei Schwangeren, wenn die Herpatitis E haben,
eine hohe Frequenz von Fullminan Herpatitis, Leberversagen bei Schwangeren.
Okay, gut. Gibt es Kommentare, Fragen?
Ich kann mir extra mal mal.